a political project that grew and grew
and spanned all over Europe for the
Mediterranean all the way north to
Britain not the European Union the Roman
Empire and here in the north of England
was its border
the last time Britain was part of a
major Europe why political structure was
2000 years ago this Hadrian's Wall was
the furthest reaches of Roman influence
and all of Britain's economy is trade as
finances were locked into the rest of
Europe
[Music]
when the Empire fell and Britain became
independent again what followed was
centuries of economic desolation so what
happens this time around does Britain
face a slumped as its soldier on or does
it even have a boom what about the
distribution does this divided nation
suffer a divided economy
for some of the answer we travel to
another old Roman town Chesterfield
traders have been selling their wares
here ever since this was a Ford two
millennia ago but despite all of that
trade with the continent sixty percent
of residents voted to leave the EU I
never wanted to turn now to Europe so we
don't want to be your friends anymore
you know all of your work training new
Europe think it's important people
coming in we go there but right to move
around but I don't want to be tied to
this huge behemoth we need to be a fuss
dynamic economy not slow and cumbersome
but might there be a price to that
independence according to Sky data one
forty-three percent of Britain's expect
their personal finances to stay the same
over the next 12 months thirty-three
percent of people think it'll get worse
three times as many as the eleven
percent who said it would get better
those in search of a metaphor might do
well to consider the crooked spire on
the church the fact that it leans so
much is largely down to the shortage of
skilled craftsmen after the Black Death
Mike controls on migration spell a
similar shortage in 21st century Britain
at the very least the vicar sees brexit
as a cry for help from those who've been
left behind we've got real human beings
here we've got real dignity and they are
if they're left out you are going to
create a situation where there is
instability where there is potential
revolt where things go wrong what we
really need to know sooner rather than
later is exactly what the plans are for
how brexit will happen when also look at
the bigger picture Britain's remain even
more nervous about the coming year our
data shows that while nineteen percent
of people think the wider economy will
improve some fifty percent think it'll
get worse seventeen percent think it'll
stay the same initially our figures do
rather chime with what we're hearing
from economists more broadly so last
year was a pretty robust year for
economic growth had two percent this
year is expected to be a lot weaker
about 1.2 percent and with inflation
expected to get up to about two point
seven percent maybe even higher that's
squeeze on families in comes around the
country could
come back
but what about the consumer since the
referendum the economy has been kept
afloat by strong consumer spending will
that continue into the new year or
collapse after the january sales where
better to ask them at the local building
society from a customer point of view we
can see that there's going to be some
nervousness going forward inflation is
deathly on the way up interest rates a
lot like that probably will be going up
there's not much further they can fall
and that gives people some concerns
about affordability so I do think we'll
have that sort of bumpy ride that we had
about three or four years ago and we
can't through that pretty well and I
don't think actually what we're facing
now with greg's it uncertainty and the
Trump factor I rightly as a bigger
challenge is what we have four or five
years ago as we came out to the last
recession and then there's business
itself are they more or less optimistic
about the future outside the EU for some
the impact is already being felt so
overnight following the brexit
announcement this particular part 41
pallets load went up by eight and a half
thousand pounds overnight the cry here
is the same as elsewhere give us some
detail on what kind of brexit it might
be especially important for those who
are already locked into trade with
Europe at the moment that business is so
easy there's no red tape you know it's
as easy for us to send a piece of
lifting equipment to the Netherlands or
hungry or France is it is to send it to
London or to Manchester if that changes
if we have to pay customs charges for
example if there's extra paperwork and
we need more admin staff here to control
all of that that's really going to eat
away at our margins nor is it just
bosses her concern about the next 12
months sky data asked employees how they
felt about the prospects for their
company forty five percent said they
thought things would stay the same in
the next year while twenty-eight percent
think it'll get worse almost double the
fifteen percent who expect an
improvement this part of the country has
had to contend with Romans and Vikings
here at the end of Hadrian's Wall is the
new castle a city that bucked the local
trend last summer with 51% voting to
remain in the referendum this was an
island of remain in the north east and
it kind of underlines the story we saw
throughout the country these urban
metropolitan areas with high migration
and strong economies voting to say in
and everyone on the outside voting to
leave indeed so cosmopolitan his new
course will become that you can now fly
in and out of here directly from New
York then again United you used to
operate the route during the summer has
cancelled it in the wake of the
referendum and the fall in the pound but
the airport itself remains optimistic we
want as open and access for UK aviation
into the the european aviation market we
want to be able to maintain connectivity
you know that's crucial for regions like
the northeast in terms of the economy in
terms of businesses and we also want
people to have you know reasonable
prices and good choice you know we are
we are very well connected to Europe and
we want that to continue for some
companies here Europe isn't just about
trade and migration it's also about
investment the EU pumped millions of
pounds of structural funds into the UK
regions every year and while that's
guaranteed until 2020 no one knows what
happens next the certainly uncertainty
and I think you know businesses are
evaluating the environment quite
carefully and you know one of the key
messages I think from the businesses and
the other partners in the Northeast is
that their voice needs to be heard in
the negotiations
in short this year will be shrouded in
yet more political fog for the time
being Britain remains a part of that
European empire meanwhile the divisions
within this country wealth income
opportunity remain as wide as ever at
Conway Sky News
[Music]